s's'écrasent sur la côte o ouest
dudu Sri Lanka. Le navire, qui
brbrûle a au large de la capitae
dedepuis 10 jours, transportait
2828 conteneurs remplis de
ceces granulés de polyéthylènen.
HuHuit d'entre eux sont déjà
totombés à l l'eau.
L Les débris de plastique se st
rérépandus sur 80 kilomètrtres
dede côte. . Le nettoyage
esest un travail de titan,
ququ'il faut recommencer
àà c chaque nouvelle marée.
L La présence de ces billes das
leles eaux peu profondes pourrat
nunuire à la a biodiversité pent
dedes années.
" "La pollution plastique
auaugmente le contenu chimique,
l'l'alcalinité, l'acidité
etet la température de l'eau".
L Les villages côtierers, qui
vivivent de pêchche et de touri,
popourraient subir d'importantes
coconséquences économiques.
" "Nous avons 4500 familles
dede pêchcheurs. En fait,
lala plupart des villageois sont
dedes pêchcheurs, donc la populn
esest très affectéeée par cette
sisituation tragique", déplore
lele prêtre dudu village.
C Ce n'est pas le seul dommage
quque pourrait causer ce porte-
coconteneurs de 186 mètrtres
dede long, puisqu'il transporte
prprès dede 300 tonnes de mazou.
M Mais pour le moment, l'incene
sesemble maîtrisisé.
S Selon le vice-amiral, même si
sasa structure demeure fragile,
ilil n'y a pas de danger que
lele vaisseau se brise et
prprovoque une marée noire.
L Les autorités du Sri Lanka ot
ououvert une enquêtete sur la fn
dodont le feu s'est propagé
etet ont promis de poursuivre
enen justice l'exploitant
dudu porte-conteneurs.
I Ici Alexie-André Bélisle,
R Radio-Canada, Montréa